hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer
and i provide content for new and
aspiring software engineers
and today we are going to be talking
about the fastest
way to become a front-end software
engineer
a front-end developer in 2021.
now this is a follow-up to the video
fastest way to become
a software engineer in 2021 i'll link it
above
but make sure you watch that first if
you haven't because today i'm going to
be
a lot more detailed and so if you don't
understand the overarching
road map to software engineering in
general
then following along with this video
will be kind of
difficult and so try to watch that first
and
let's get to it so step number one
along with learning how to create
paragraphs and titles
in your html also learn how to
incorporate
forms tables and embed images
and videos in your html now this is
something i didn't know was
very important until i was learning to
develop and coding
forms specifically forms are responsible
for
i'd say at least at least 50 to 60
of the interaction you'll get from apps
and websites
and so think about facebook facebook
you have you know the status section and
you can
edit your status or post a new status
and upload something
that in this bare core is a form
same thing with the blog post if you're
on medium.com
and you put in a title and you start
writing out a new blog post and then
press submit
again that in its most basic form
is a form that is this yes
and the most basic you know explanation
possible
those are html forms and so with forms
they allow users to
interact and to upload things and to
post things and
edit and this is very something that's
very important to do
specifically when building apps because
you want users to be able
to create things edit things post
things and delete things and a lot of
times that comes from
forms now when we go into images and
videos
i know some of you will say oh but i can
just put images
you know in my css or things like that
you can
but if we're talking about search engine
optimization
it's best to put those things in your
html
if you're just you know using images
just for the aesthetics of
things and you're just making a
background and leaving it there
then it is fine to put on on on css
but if you are using images as a add-on
to
you know your articles or your sites or
you know just supporting documentation
it's best to put it in your html because
that makes it more seo friendly and if
we're talking about a company that
you're working for
you want things to be very search engine
optimized because we want clients to be
able to gravitate towards that company's
sites and apps and you know find it
easily and things like that because
in this video we're talking about more
skills that
companies will want to see from you not
just
things that you will do just for the fun
of it
we're talking about skills to know and
skills to learn to get
hired by a company as a front-end
engineer
and those three things forms tables
and embedding images and videos in your
html
are part of that so step number two
now moving on to css it's very important
that you
know how to manipulate colors and images
in your css
so you know now how to you know add
images and add
background colors and change background
colors from red to blue in your css
that's very important and there's a very
you know crucial
step one however when was the last time
you went
on a site and their colors were just
blue
and red and you know like things
now have a certain um design aesthetic
to it things flow a certain way they
have
gradients they have a certain um like
borders that you know circulate a
certain way being able to know how to
manipulate that in css
is very important because some people
think that the images you
get are it's that's what you have to use
the way you get it is how you have to
use it
but that's not true at all that would be
terrible
if that was true what you get is just a
starting point
now learn how to yeah manipulate the
shading of the image manipulate
the sharpness and all of that through
css and that will really set you
on a great path in terms of design going
more into design learn a css
framework specifically bootstrap
something that
i don't think is talked about much
is the importance of responsive design
this is something that i heard nobody
talk about until i was learning it
in real time responsive design
here is what it is you are on you know
facebook.com
on your computer then you decide to take
a walk and you pull up facebook.com
on your phone odds are
just because you went on your phone
didn't you know the design didn't go
haywire you know the coloring didn't go
crazy and the text still looked good
it you know you were still readable in
all of this
but on your web browser your text is
obviously bigger because it has you know
more space to fill and the banner is
bigger because again more spaceflight
and all of that
that's responsive web design being able
to design in such a way that
no matter the screen size that the user
is
using the styling still stays consistent
readable and you know very flattering
and appealing this is something that is
so
hard and so time consuming and not
hard in terms of like difficult to learn
or understand
more because of how fidgety css is
if you are having trouble with css it's
not because you are a bad
developer or you don't know enough no it
just means
you need more practice because the thing
is css no matter if you've been working
for
one month to 10 years css is just
something that is just a necessary evil
you will likely still always have
problems with it unless they you know
switch it up to make it easier and
better and all of that
it's difficult and it's fragile that's
the word css is very fragile you think
you you know created something one way
perfectly and then
you decide to change the font size and
then everything goes haywire
that is just it's a necessary evil
and so where bootstrap comes in is it's
a css framework
that really allows the process to be of
design
specifically responsive design be a lot
um simpler and just less time consuming
because now instead of with css if you
wanted to code something responsibly
in css you would need to declare the
window size you're coding for
in each you know block of code and
recode out from the ground up and so
if you're coding for a computer then a
tablet
and mobile devices that's like coding
out three
different projects from the ground up
where bootstrap
it really takes all of that away and
allows you to just
style things regularly and through
you know their process and everything
things end up being
able to be altered for tablet viewing
for mobile viewing for
window viewing so learn
a css framework specifically bootstrap
because
again that's what companies are using
that's what companies are doing and
that's what
likely would be expected of you as a
front-end engineer so
the next thing you need to do staying on
the frameworks you know
side of things is learn a javascript
framework specifically the more popular
ones like react
angular or view these are the three most
popular frameworks for front-end
development
and so you know if we're trying to
get hired as soon as we can then
best to stay with one of these now
if you were to ask me if you were to ask
me which framework to choose of the
three
i would tell you react that is what i
would advise
because a little on react react was
developed by software engineers from
facebook
it's maintained by facebook it's used
through
all of facebook's apps and so therefore
it's very well documented
and you know it's very robust because of
this commercial
backing the resources you have to learn
it are
very very vast and very very wide and
community is very wide and on top of
that
react is a fantastic gateway
to mobile development because for mobile
development
you would use something like react
native and so if you already know react
for you know the website
of things then you will have a much
smoother transition
going into mobile development however
react's learning curve is like an
s so it's slow slow slow slow then you
kind of dip
a little bit because it's like oh my
gosh like i don't know what i don't know
and then you shoot up because you
it just clicks and then you go back to
being the standard
small learning increments and things
like that react
it took me tens of hours i want to say
it took me about a hundred hours to be
honest
for me to finally get to a place where i
felt comfortable enough to
use react and i didn't feel like
an utter failure using react
because it's not like something like
html html you have your rules
and once you do them things work the way
they're supposed to
you need a paragraph put the p tag and
boom there's your paragraph there's
nothing there's
no ifs ands or buts about it
however we act
it's less about the rules and more about
the practice
in terms of understanding things because
yes of course you know it has like their
rules and their process
but it's not for me it didn't
it wasn't intuitive it didn't follow my
flow of thinking until i practiced it
again and again react to something that
you can't just keep reading for you to
understand
or to finally understand and get the
technology
you have to keep practicing and so keep
building things keep practicing
over and over again until one day you
wake up and you're like
oh oh okay i understand the first five
steps i should always do
and the next three steps i should always
do and is by
starting to have that procedure in your
development that things start to come
together and so keep that in mind don't
give
up on react just because you know you
see
how you know difficult it is or anything
that is the way
it goes for most people
it just that means you're that means
you're doing it right if you
want to you know just give up and just
leave and everything it means you're on
the right track
so keep that in mind when learning this
but like i said
you can learn any different javascript
framework i recommend react
angular or view and so you know
do your own research and see which um
you
prefer um because you know it's this is
your road you know i'm not
i'm just here for advice this is your
road please subscribe
if you enjoyed this video or have seen
my content and would like to be part of
this community
but there we have it everybody the tips
i have for you to become a front-end
software engineer the in the fastest
time
just the easiest way possible in 2021
so please leave a like and a comment and
i will see
you all soon bye y'all